Jennifer what are some of the things
that a young adult author needs to know
about their readership well I think one
of the most important things to know is
that your readership or it's the
category you're in main protagonist
needs to be a teenager now there is a
range for what that age is the sweet
spot is somewhere around 16 years old
and if you're writing character much
younger than that your book is probably
going to be middle grade 12 13 is
probably going to skew a little younger
although the genre has opened up a
little and 16 17 18 even College seems
somewhat appropriate now in terms of the
readership I mean I think the only thing
you need to know is that their fans are
there they're very passionate they're
looking for new material that they can
fall in love with one of the interesting
things I have encountered is that they
like to read hard books a lot whereas I
coming into it had suspected that there
would be more readers out there I
actually tend to read more on my Kindle
and a lot of the team readers that come
to me they want hard copies they really
still love to consume hard books and I
know there's been a lot of apocalyptic
predictions about how you know there
aren't going to be print books anymore
but based on my encounters I don't think
that's true at all and so yeah that's
really it they're really excited they're
passionate they want to read their big
readers and I think it's great that kids
are still reading the other thing I see
a lot is that essentially Harry Potter
which is you know JK Rowling's series
produced a whole generation of readers
so they've grown up now and they're
still reading and they still love to
read so she kind of did a huge service
for every other author out there
you